hello everyone - Jeremy and today we're
going to do a little tour of the triple
add extensions so there is a ripple on
github so if you want to follow along
there is actually a binder link you can
run the same presentation as I have at
the same time or you can also check it
out later if you want
okay so before we start I'm currently
working at constic lock on stock we
specialize in the scientific computing
so we work a lot in Jupiter ecosystem
that means building tools for Jupiter
and building on top of Jupiter
we work for support on the Jupiter live
extensions i buy widgets and also on
steep response tools such as extensors
and so the C++ columns so if you have
more questions or if you want to know
more about what we do if you talk to me
at the end and check the website here if
you want to find me your talk later you
can also do that on github and Twitter
all right so when we talk about
extending Jupiter there is actually a
lot of different ways to do so maybe not
99 but there is this blog post from
Julie who is a quad core Twitter of
Jupiter working on Jupiter hub and he
took the time to go through all our
different kind of extraction points we
have at the moment for extending through
Peter it's quite funny because the first
one is the Jeep Arabic stanchion this is
exactly what we're going to cover today
but it's not only about this it's also
about notebook extensions server
extensions superior honors ipython magic
and so on so as I said we are not going
to cover all of this today only the GPL
extension which is already quite quite a
lot so let's get to it so about 2p lab
quickly
it's the next-gen UI for project Jupiter
so you can think of it as the kind of
the succession of the classic notebook
it turned the version 100 early this
summer so that is quite important
because that means it's both ready for
users which was already case like one
and a half years ago but it more
is also ready for developers so it means
that if you want to make an exception
for GP lab the API is now stable until
of course we reach 2.0 where we're going
to break everything but yeah that's the
main point and that's why I wanted to
show you now like a tour of these
extractions that could be that can be
built as of today while the main selling
point of super drive is that is
extensible by design that means that
basically everything in the develop is
an extension if you make an extension
for GPIB has the same right is kind of
lives on the same level as all of the
others when you install to fill up from
peep or coder
you got your opening actually to get 60
of them have sis extensions but you
don't need to necessarily see all of
them that point you look at the year at
the UI because we're going to show you
an example of call centers afterwards
yeah so all of these extensions are
built in JavaScript typescript the using
NPM to to publish them so this is really
built the kind of the modern way of
making JavaScript web apps as of 2019
which is also a huge improvement
compared to the classical book all right
so a quick a quick word on core
extensions so we're actually currently
looking at GP wrap and for example if
you look at this file browser this is an
exception in terms of HP wrap it just
that ships automatically when you store
it the same goes for the console so here
I'll put the console can type code
execute code this is also an extension
that is built-in Shapira
and of course there's also the notebook
exception does two one IDs with the
notebooks and that shows media notebook
in the UI right here but today I want to
focus more on the third-party extensions
that means all the expressions that we
as developers can build on top of you
pair up give you a little idea of what
we can do put a little video here so I'm
going to play it and show what it means
at the same time so this is running a
simulation and on the left side you have
3d scene
of a robot on the right side you have a
notebook that actually controls the
simulation so this is pretty nice
because here the only thing we did was
to extend the the GP lab interface and
use these extension points to basically
be able to do this so here we have a 3d
model on the left side but technically
could also be a like a real physical
robot and the good the good thing about
this is if we can actually reuse the
whole you either already exists in a
repeater such as two notebooks and
consoles and so on alright so that was
just a little intro to give you an idea
of what we're going to talk about so
we're going to start with the ten of
them that's not going to be like the
first batch of extensions we're going to
look at then we're going to look at ten
more but a little bit faster because we
don't have that much time and idea that
we show you a little bit what is coming
up so exceptions that have been released
that's the one that we're going to look
at now and at the end we're going to
look at the ones are going to be
released in the future okay so why
important thing when we work with
notebooks especially in teams is being
able to version code the notebook is not
different on codes it's just coding
stars and and again we get a JSON file
that we need to put somewhere and share
with all people so there's an extension
in GPA lab coded fill up get extension
and wait does it serve it cropped but
yeah so there is an icon on the left
side you can click on and you get this
kids
UI so this presentation is actually git
repo so you see all of my comments here
so the history can go here and I see
that my notebook has changed I can stage
it write a message and press commit can
also for later strategies use it using
this pattern as well as pushing new
changes using this one so basically like
simple git workflow but that is usually
then enough for like a basic work with
notebooks but the good thing is that you
can actually use kids also in a turbine
or and this extension is just hooking
itself on the existing kid comment that
you have installed on your machine so
you are free to basically choose what
you want if it's just hook quick and
dirty commits in the UI that's perfectly
fine and also a bit more complexed
reverse and so on using the terminal
this is definitely possible alright so
that was about it
but before we actually commit notebooks
we often want to know what change is in
the book and we want to be able to give
them and fortunately there is an
extension for that called anti dime so
when bidam is actually a tool that you
can run the other common line integrates
rewire with get so you can configure
gates so it actually shows and be damned
if and not give thieves and it's very
useful because if you take a classic
notebook in the JSON format
you're going to see a difference on
files which is not very handy but NB
time is able to recognize the cells and
to a cell by cell diff which is very
very useful and here this is even better
because we can actually use it in super
lab so for example I have this cell I'm
going to change this value execute it
quick to seven a notebook and I can
click on this and we see that a
basically a diff of the notebook we even
see the video I executed before because
now it's added to the output so it's
also shown here so it could be used to
really make sure that we are not
committing outputs for example if the
policy we have in our git repositories
to never commit outputs then we can
really quickly see that and also yeah
have a better diff that and just just
advice okay so steer about gates D thing
and now let's say we want to also ensure
that everybody is using the same code
format that's great because there is an
extension for this so it's called the
code formatter this succession is meant
to be used as a kind of add mystic code
formatter extension so
basically supporting multiple languages
not only Python but also multiple
formatters here I'm going to show you
the how it works with black but
basically you could do the same with
Auto pipe eight and other four matters
so this is very badly formatted cell and
I would like to format it using black so
what I can do is I can open the comment
palettes and search for format and here
since I have installed black it shows up
in the list I will have installed
another formatter there will be another
entry so I can just hit enter and now
the cell has been formatted so this this
is really useful if you want to have
first if you want to limit the number of
dips you have with other other
colleagues or something like this for
support says I have not been modified
they will stayed with the same code side
in our inner repo okay next one is the
table of context option so it's going to
be pretty quick because it does one
thing but it does it well it as this
little icon here on the left side and
you can navigate through new notebook so
it's basically two kind of passing all
of the titles of the Malcolm Malcolm
cells the creates kind of entry parts
for you and kind of anchor anchors so
you can navigate through the notebook
very easy so very useful if you have a
very large notebook I want to basically
jump around in a matter of seconds okay
quick open is meant to bring you the
functionalities of this control shifty
shortcut you get in other IDs in his
code sublime pycharm and so also you
want to fuzzy search a file that's what
you can do with quick open so you get
this little icon on the left and let's
say I want to open the readme file and
search for Remy
press enter and I get my file open okay
next one is a sidecar so I think I would
need to change the ID ratio because I
don't think you were seeing the left
side
scream never mind yeah the sidecar so
the idea with the this extension is that
interpreted AB you have on the left side
different entry points for extensions
here but I don't know if any of you knew
that you can actually have things on on
the right side of your P lab so you can
actually do that here by doing the
right-click and switch side by side that
will bring this little icon on the other
side and basically move the extension on
the other side and the sidecar extension
does the same but programmatically so
you can use it to display widgets on the
right side here I took the example of
going to take a pipe I can pass as an
example we chat sure to put on the right
side so I pack invest is being developed
by Martha and you can also check it out
so you will see in a minute how well
it's doing so I'm creating a creating in
canvas so we can see our canvas as a
HTML canvas you get if you work with
JavaScript and you can draw things on
and here I'm going to draw a face it's a
poker face not very happy but what's
there in on the canvas so I'm going to
scroll and it's already kind of already
gone right I don't even see where it is
so that's the whole point of using the
sidecar exception is that instead I can
put it on the right side I can start
scrolling with notebooks and it's going
to stay there even better now we can
actually make the face happy and start
modifying the widget and yeah so it's
also useful if you work with maps for
example you want to have a map on the
side using a pilot and make some
modifications so now we're going to keep
that face with us the rest of the
presentation
now I'm kidding it's not true it's
closest okay all right so speaking about
drawing things there's an exception
called draw IO for a GP driver so maybe
you've already used this website called
draw dot IO you can draw diagrams and
then export them you can send them to XM
eros or a PNG and SVG and that's the
great thing about this trip Arab
ecosystem is that you can actually reuse
existing libraries very easily so that's
- that's what happened with this
extension so that this is basically
wrapper around Road on Io and it means
that if you go back to the launcher can
create a diagram here and you get the
same thing you can start creating your
diagram and then save it to a PNG and
potentially embedded in your notebook so
you don't have to leave the HP lab
anymore can just do everything in the
same interface alright so one thing I've
heard quite often is people want to to
be able to use this face that you have
here at the top of trippy wrap which is
usually empty but if you use this top
extension this won't be the case anymore
because now we can start making use of
it this is particularly useful if you
want to be able to put some indicators
one of them dies yeah it's quite use
this to show the memory usage of system
metrics so that's what the top bar does
exposes the space for other extensions
to place indicators or other widgets in
there and for support this one is like
little switch to toggle the theme very
easily instead of going to settings and
so on I can be useful to some people and
here we have the ability to put some
text so yeah just put the name of the
presentation so we know where what we're
doing at the moment another thing you
can do is you can actually rearrange the
the different extensions here so we can
drag and drop them if you want okay so
for those of you working with seeker and
who want to basically run sequel queries
very easily in trippy lab there is
superdad sequel exception the same as
before we can go back to the launcher
and click on score and here we basically
enter a URL to the to this database we
want you to use so start to type sequel
right that is because in my examples
repo here I have
examples an example database so testdb
enter and now I can explore this
database very easily in trippy lab can
look at what is in the employees table
and then I can go back invoices and I
can also select folks up or select all
from invoices where total I think is to
that greater than five control-enter and
I'll have all of my invoices that have a
total greater than five of course if you
know sick or against to a bit more
advanced things like followed by tort or
oDesk support and basically that's what
you get
so that's useful when you have sequel
queries and put it in your Python code
say you see correctly me for example we
still want to be able to run those
sequel queries kind of like like this
like a one-shot query just to make sure
that it work okay so last one for the
first batch is called the sell tags
maybe it's also like some kind of hidden
feature of the notebooks but not vanish
we have metadata about the cells the
some of this metadata is all the tags so
if you go here to the this section here
did not book tours you see that you have
possibility to add tags so let's go back
to this and let's say this is a special
special cell and now we have a tag
called special I can click on the other
side but then I can select this tag here
and select all sides with this tag and I
now I'm back to the other one I actually
marked before so this is useful if you
want to force up or navigate quickly in
a notebook like this but it's also
useful in the from sample if you create
a pipeline on a CI system and you want
to force up or format cells to matically
based on their tags or to more advanced
stuff that you can do programmatically
all right so as I said now we looked a
little bit more in 2004 in ten of the
extensions and the time all are coming
but we're not going to spend as much
time just to give you an idea what is it
variable so one once again it's like the
whole purpose here today is to just give
you an idea the extensions we have and
the fact that you period is not you know
liking behind the classic notebooks that
extensions are being ported over to
prefer lab and exit as usable as the
classic notebook
okay so first one is to go to the
definition extension and as the name
suggests so for example if you have used
other IDs you know that you can usually
do a right-click go to the finishing or
click on f12 or GD using them and it
brings you to wear something was defined
so in case of fractions if you do that
you will be able to come back to the
where the function was defined yeah so
again this is like breaking IDE like the
truth to - perhaps we don't have to
switch over between two different IDs if
you if you are looking for these kind of
features something very similar is the
droopier lab LSP exception and LS P
stands for language server protocol this
is already being used in other editors
to give you more like install
introspection utilities for for your IDs
and the good news is that we can
actually integrate that with trippy lab
so it's still kind of a work in progress
but the results are pretty pretty good
already and it's already possible to try
it on binder if you want to just go to
the repo okay so maybe some of you have
heard about vara which is a tool that
turns your notebooks into a two web
application and dashpots yeah so there
is also a period extension for for whare
I will show you a little example so
let's say we have this notebook here
this is the basic notebook you get also
in the documentation of water that can
interact with it but I'm still seeing
the code and I want to see what it will
look like
and start sharing with you water so
there is this little icon here render
with water I can click on it and on the
right side I see the preview of the
notebook rendered with water it is also
usable here and you can actually stop et
right or middle book on the left side
the using the render unsaved checkbox
here it will automatically reload your
preview as you type okay so speaking of
live previous one is more work for
educational purposes is the Python pipe
code extension so if you are interested
in knowing how your source code is being
you know translating to buy a bike code
you can use this extension so it's the
same kind of thing you type Python code
and and then you get the bike code on
the right side that is being
automatically shown okay so my per clip
is probably one of the most used
blotting libraries and we've been using
this multi beam line for years and it's
been working real well that gives you
static images so now there is this MPL I
buy widgets they can use in GP lab and
it comes with with this search period my
particular expansion and where does
basically add some kind of interactivity
around the process you make with my club
my Bradley so this is pretty nice
because you don't have to rewrite your
products you can use the same API as
you've been using for a long time and my
prototype API but still get some basic
interactivity ok so after we also want
to know what kind of variables we have
in our color at the given moment and
this is what the viable inspector
extension is doing so here you can see
that as a as we type we get create some
variables and we have this right panel
that shows what variables are being our
life in our kernel at the moment is a
bit similar to what MATLAB is doing with
these survivors you have on the side I
also has support for showing vampire
race as a matrices it's pretty useful so
the Stila but introspections
and that kind of looking under the hood
or what is happening
there's this CounterSpy extension that
you can use and it's especially useful
if you're making an extension for
triple-a is talking to a colonel or
making a custom ipad widgets so what it
does is physically intercepting all of
the messages being sent to a color and
being received from a colonel or so you
can physically see what is happening
with your extension as you build it okay
so I think there are three left for this
second batch so it's going to be a bit
more random and this one is about
integrating Heroku in trippy lab and
this is especially useful if you want to
for sample in one click deploy an
application to Heroku using a notebook
so again this is taking voila as an
example but it could be also any other
Python Python application it adds a
little kind of UI sugar on top of here
oh cool come online so you can do
everything in Jupiter okay so let's say
you work at a company that's kind of
enforces a very strict way of how
notebook should be written and this is
where you can use this template library
or the templates extension so you can
create templates save them and then you
can create new notebooks using templates
that you choose here so let's say you
what you have a logo of a company at the
very top then this is two extension you
can use for that okay and just to show
that it's not only about features and
extensions with also but seem so themes
again they have the same kind of level
as your other extensions if you filled
up so we can create new theme using the
extensions and this one is the matter
darker once it's installed it's going to
show up here and click and click on it
and then switch to the new theme
alright so where do we find all of this
yeah I agree it's it's a very
interesting question so there are three
different ways compared to other IDs
there is no marketplace yet for Java we
don't know yet it's going to be the case
or not but at the moment we can
get up and search for topics so the true
period extension topic that requires
people writing extensions to actually
put this topic but this is often the
case because it's documented in the
cookie cutter for extensions so you can
go there is 140 at the moment there is
also the exception manager which is now
part of GP lab it's not enabled by
default but you can enable it here and
click on enable extension manager it's
going to add this little icon here on
the left side and then you can look at
the one that you have installed and
course also search in the in the box for
new extensions and finally there is also
a awesome contributor github repo so
this is not only about Shapira but also
other computer resources there's a
section about triple extension so if
you're looking for other computer
related tools yeah and it's the
difference with the rest is that it's
curated so it's kind of e to the pro
board so it means that usually we get
some high quality content there all
right so what's next as I said now we're
talking about extensions are in the
making but not released yet and one of
them is a debugger UI for Jupiter lab
and this is what we've been working on
that construct with the folks from two
sigma as well and it basically brings
you a debugger interface to GP lab so
it's a everything is being developed on
github so if you are interested you can
also check it out there's a rich text
mode exception being bit by the interns
at Cal Poly in the US so it's like a
WYSIWYG editor for markdown starts
same kind of thing as you get on using
word package installer to install pip
and color packages without using this
tip magic or pip comments in under book
commenting extension similar to the
Google Docs
style where you can put comments and
then you can share the box with the
comments with your colleagues
and many more of course so yeah so if
you're interested in this if you to
check out all of these resources with
that say thank you and if you have any
questions just come to tweet at the end
[Applause]
hello so we have a time for one or two
questions left does anybody have any
questions for Jeremy yeah yes thank you
so much for a great talk and great
extensions as well and I was just
wanting to ask um like if you're working
with a puker
you know our requirements don't text you
can have an approach project or an
environment Akiyama with Conda are you
thinking about doing something similar
for like Jupiter extensions or is there
a good reason why you think that
wouldn't be a way to go yeah so the
question is about how do you manage all
these extensions the similar way as as
with a requirement of text or have a
medallion board and at the moment so
there are two ways of doing that so some
some extensions are being kind of
bundled in the Python packages so if
they focus on put some extensions here
that the mode require a component on the
server side as well which is the case
for the the get exceptions and here what
you can do is you can actually install
automatically the GPIB extension by
putting it in the right folder and then
rebuilding the GPU lab so that's one way
and the other ways to install it by hand
using the trip arab repeater lab
extension install command like here and
it's going to install the extension in
your environment yeah so that's the two
different ways at the moment but I agree
they will be great you have some some
help spec to be able to manage
extensions and also there are versions
of it bit easier way
thank you very much chairman we fought a
wonderful talk and I think you can enjoy
the coffee break now see you later
[Applause]